To quote you simply 2 numbers,
hum,
if we take for example the Algerians
who are the main nationality
beneficiary of residence permits,
today
42% of them were unemployed or inactive
in two thousand ten seven,
that is,
3 times more than the French.
Neither as unemployed or inactive,
It means neither in employment,
nor in study, nor in retirement.
And maybe 1/2 data
on the type of value-added immigration
higher or not that we can have,
today we have about 35% of the immigrants
who have no diploma
or 1 level patents C E P,
which is two and a half times more than the French are.
Migratoryy,
with spikes on the other hand
on some Syrian immigrations.
So in reality,
beyond the number which is 1 subject in itself,
and also
the question of the nature of immigration
which is received.